you
professor Toure ellingson member of the
economic science prize committee thank
you very much for discussing the 2009
economics prize for us could we begin by
you telling us who's been awarded this
year's prize yes this year's price goes
one-half to Elinor Ostrom a political
scientists at the University of Indiana
and one-half to Oliver Williamson who is
an economist at Berkeley and so what
have they been awarded the prize for
well ostrom has been awarded for her
work on economic governance especially
the governance of common pool resources
and Oliver Williamson also for economic
governance and especially the boundaries
of the firm and so the place has been
shared this year and you mentioned the
phrase economic governance what exactly
did do both half of the price have in
common well what they have in common is
they try to understand how nan market
institutions work and why we have them
and that is something that economists
have not been paying as much attention
to as to the workings of markets and so
could you give examples of what nan
market institutions are and why it's
important study there oh yes so Allah
Williamson has primarily been trying to
understand the existence of firms and
elinor ostrom the existence of
associations in particular groups of
users of local natural resources and so
they were exploring nan market
institutions was that was that because
they it was a particular interest or
were they interested in these
institutions or were they particularly
aunty market institutions well I don't
think that you could call any of them
anti-market
but it's evident that a lot of resource
allocation takes place outside of
markets and no matter whether we like
markets or not we need to understand why
that is so and both in the case of
ostrom and Williamson they see that
there are important efficiencies to be
had that you're sometimes cannot have in
markets so if we if we go through each
half the price separately we'll start
with the achievements of Elinor Ostrom
what more particular was she studying
and why well her research is very much
based on empirical studies of how local
natural resources you know like pastures
like dams for irrigation groundwater
woods fish stocks you name it she wanted
to understand how user management of
those resources actually work in
practice and it seems like a very
interesting field to study were there
any preconceptions about how these these
areas are managed yes and that's
important because both in economics and
in biology there was this preconception
that the common property will always be
mismanaged and hence you have two
solutions either you split it up so all
properties owned by individuals or you
involve the government and you have
government regulating the usage through
for example taxes and quotas and Elinor
Ostrom after performing her own studies
and also looking at what other people
were finding she concluded that the
common property regimes could actually
in many cases work better than either of
the two alternatives that have been
proposed
do you have any examples of how this
work successfully oh yes there are lots
and lots of examples so the challenge is
to find the most striking one so one one
example I like a lotta is is grasslands
in in and around Mongolia because if you
look at the satellite photos you will
see that there are some areas that are
clearly green and then you will see
other areas where there's been a lot of
degradation so looks almost brown and
then you overlay national boundaries and
then you can see that all the green is
in Mongolia whereas the yellow is in
China and Russia where they tried the
first collectivization and then at least
China tried also privatization and
neither of those classical solutions
worked well whereas the common property
regime with you know mobile herders had
the classic way of of managing
grasslands in Mongolia worked much
better from an environmental point of
view and not because they had less
animals is the same same grazing
pressure overall but the traditional
methods just work much better it's but
it's very interesting with tradition
works better than than anything that
modern management comes up with but when
when looking at all these examples of
how this works are there any universal
rules to success yes ostrom has
identified a number of such rules and
what we find maybe most striking are the
following two first that it matters how
rules are being created it's not just
the rule itself but how it comes to be
if people if the users themselves are
involved in creating the rules the rule
tend to work better also being more
legitimate you get more compliance with
the road
second it also matters how the rule
rules are being monitored and and how
sanctions are being put into place
systems work better when users
themselves engage in monitoring and also
when they engage in sanctioning of Free
Riders so when they have a vested
interest in what they're doing yes yes
so having third parties from the outside
coming in to do the management there's
not time to work as well as when the
users themselves are actively engaged
you briefly mentioned a limitation there
are there any more limitations this sort
of model you mean to in were in which
ways but may not work so well well this
is sure surely there are but but these
are these are the ones that we think are
most most striking most surprising and
so you've mentioned example a very nice
example of success at a sort of
nationwide level a quite restricted
level is this something that can be
scaled up is it is that okay we talk
about common common community ideals but
can we can we expand that to common
global ideals so for example with the
issues with climate change yes so this
is one of the questions that I know that
Elinor Ostrom has been much involved
with over the last decade or so and so
what what we know that we can learn from
her work is that you can often scale the
scale up from two small communities they
can start to operate cooperating once
there and of them works well internally
how you can scale it up globally it's
not absolutely obvious to me or I think
to her but one guess would be that with
all the modern communication technology
some some of the tricks that work well
in small groups
could also work well globally I think of
naming and shaming for example with
today's technology something stupid that
you do in Stockholm will be known
worldwide after just a couple of hours
we hesitate so if we turn now to olive
oil lemon and his achievements are being
awarded the prize he looked at a very
different sector could you go into a bit
of detail about what what he explored
and why was exploring yes so his
question is really not about user groups
or associations but about commercial
firms and he wanted to understand when
will you have interaction when we have
transactions conducted inside the
boundaries of the firm's and when would
the parties prefer to negotiate their
way to an agreement in in the
marketplace so that was the big question
that had been posed already by earlier
laureates and in particular by Ronald
Coase who got the price in in 91 but
cause only gave a partial answer to this
question KO's said that technology is
not going to be the whole answer you
need to understand what is the problems
of transacting and what Williamson has
done is to flesh out that
answer in much more detail so that we
can take it to data and see if if you
could have a theory that stands up in a
scientific way so how do markets and
firms differ in the way they approach
the same subject and what did Oliver
Williamson discover that firms do better
well so his argument is that the problem
with market interaction is that you need
both parties to agree and that means
that I have an incentive to bargain
strategically with you and vice versa we
may spend resources on that and we may
in the end we may fail to agree indeed
because we push too hard within the firm
one of us will have authority and we'll
be able to decide we don't need both
parties to agree to everything so firms
are good in at resolving conflict the
only question is then what are firms bad
at and what Williams Norg use is that
firms of bad at limiting the abuse of
power the central executive officer can
resolve conflicts both among
subordinates and and among others and
himself but it's hard for him or her to
refrain from abusing that power so given
a very nice description arrow of what
firms deal s effectively is is
Williamson's there is a way of managing
and effective behavior within firms well
yes it is because what he says is is the
following that if if it's very important
that you don't disagree okay so maybe
you have some assets some knowledge that
is only valuable in a certain
relationship so you have what he calls a
relationship specific asset then you may
want to move there
inside the boundaries of the firm in
order to not risk the costs of of
disagreement so this is something that
nowadays is being taught that business
rules all over the world that you know
what what you need to think about when
you decide to make or buy or when you
decide to engage in a takeover a merger
so something that's been discussed
globally and being being commemorated by
firms all around the world oh yes
absolutely so if we swim move towards
the the motivation swords awarding the
prize we discuss briefly what the what
the to have supplies share and the as
United the announcement these have been
given for four theories and discussions
that have been occurring some years
beforehand so was there any sort of
recent development in both theories or
any recent sort of breakthrough which
provided a compelling reason for
awarding the prize this year well that's
a good question i would say that as is
the case most often there is this
gradual corroborations of work so in
Williamson's case you know we did much
of his work in the 70s and 80s and then
gradually it's been corroborated
empirically there have been other
theories come to some extent competing
theories and we want to find out which
of those theories are relatively most
important which of them can we feel most
confident
if we award so I wouldn't say that there
is something dramatic that has happened
over say the last five years it's just
the accumulation of evidence in favor of
the theory and the lack maybe also to
some extent of some competing theory
that that would prove him wrong and it
said something in general that is a more
complex for something like a field like
economic sciences because in the
physical sciences of biological sciences
one waits for there to be proved but in
economics one not only has to wait for
there to be proved that one has to do
that within the cycles of human behavior
does that present more difficulties when
it comes to awarding prizes well yes and
no I think there is a misconception
actually about the difficulties of
testing theories and economics relative
to other sciences if you compare it to
medicine for example often we live for a
very long time before we're sure whether
a particular theory in in medicine is is
correct and I think about astronomy so
on and so forth and there are theories
in economics that has that have been
tested down to the last decimal so yes I
think so on average if you compare to
physics for example we have to live with
a bit more uncertainty and we have to
use slightly different methods but it's
it's a matter of degree not a matter of
sort I think and so the first prize in
economic sciences rewards in 1969 which
makes us the 40th anniversary and this
this year marks the first time that I
that a female laureate has received the
prize are we now turning a corner in
terms of awarding the prize to female
economists
well it's that's it's hard to speculate
about that in particular since we don't
want to tie down future committees I
guess it's a reasonable gas but it's
certainly a reasonable guess that a long
be another 40 years before we see a
second female laureate at the same time
the diffraction of full professors and
economics who are female it's not
increasing all that fast so we I think
we'll have to wait and see and you know
whether whether this is a change in
trend or not you saw the chemistry price
it's the first female this year since
1963 45 years so hopefully the wooden
the price issue will provide some form
of inspiration yes I think that that's
the nice thing I believe at least it
proves too young scholars that it's not
necessary to be male in order to win
this prices it's a positive message so
final question have you managed to
contact both laureates yes we have had
they react well they were both very
pleased of course and as I said the
humbled and I guess they need to take
have some time to to take in the full
ramifications of obtaining this award in
the case of Williamson he was woken up
at half past three in the night so I
guess in particular for him will take
some time to digest
for selling synthetic
you